herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
philosophie in zeiten die uns wahrlich
geduld abverlangen historische laufen
durch die krise wer möchte das nicht
heute tauchen die rub zur
philosophischen quelle dieser ruhe zur
antiken schule der store heißt kennen
wir die story kauf von flotten kalender
sprüchen von mark aurel und seneca doch
worum geht es im kern eine der
wichtigsten social lektionen lautet
lernen mit dem abgrund und dem sicheren
ende zu rechnen
deshalb drehe ich hier gleich mal die
sanduhr und spreche später in der
sendung mit der story expertin anna
schritten wie man angesichts des
sicheren endes gelassen bleibt jetzt
zuerst ist mir auch der philosoph
richard david precht aus düsseldorf
zugeschaut wird ganz herzlich willkommen
ab recht erbrecht sich mit sicherheit
der bekannteste philosoph deutschlands
und aus bestseller-autor haben sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mit
materiellen sorgen zu kämpfen in dieser
krise sind sie bis an den stoisch
gelassen durch die krise gekommen
ich würde sagen alles in allem ja ich
habe aber auch das glück gehabt selber
nicht von corona betroffen zu sein auch
in meinem namen umfeld die menschen die
mehr gibt sind eben auch keine starken
gesundheitlichen probleme gehabt haben
und unter den bedingungen unter denen
von ihnen gerade angesprochenen
materiellen bedingungen bin ich
eigentlich alles in allem ganz gelassen
durch die nun waren ja aber die
philosophen und philosophinnen doch sehr
gefragt in dieser krise auch sie wurden
bestimmt ganz oft angefragt haben sich
auch geäußert so corona was kann man
eigentlich als philosoph spezifisch
jetzt zu dieser pandemie beitragen
doch ich glaube unglaublich viel das ist
ja eher die frage was man von den vielen
gedanken die man sich dazu machen kann
auswählt ich meine auf der einen seite
ist ein interessantes thema dass
menschen die auf dem weg waren sich mehr
und mehr für defizitäre computer zu
halten also in dem sichtweise des
digitalzeitalters anfang an maschinen
maß zu nehmen und nicht mehr an der
natur jetzt merken dass sie das andere
der künstlichen intelligenz sind das
heißt dass die biologische lebewesen
sind dass sie verletzlich sind dass sie
sich verhalten
dass sie ihre population keinen
größtmöglichen schaden zufügen
das ist alles ziemlich interessant weil
ich oft das gefühl gehabt aber wir haben
das eigentlich vergessen bei der inso
technologischen welten leben das wäre zb
ein wichtiger aspekt und anderer
wichtiger aspekt der mich im augenblick
beschäftigt ist es gibt ja als
staatsbürgerliche pflichten wie die
anordnungen zu folgen dass man abstand
halten soll das was ich nicht zu so
vielen trifft das am masken tragen soll
es natürlich sehr interessant zu sehen
wie die menschen damit umgehen dass der
allergrößte teil der menschen von reger
urteilskraft gebrauch macht und einsieht
dass ist gut ist und auch
staatsbürgerliche pflicht sich daran zu
halten also ist die schwächsten in der
gesellschaft hielt und auf der anderen
seite aber eben auch zu sehen das ist
eine kleine krakeelenden minderheit gibt
die das nicht begreift also ganz viele
verschiedene themen zu denen man sich
philosophisch äußern kann
auffallend ist ja auch das eine
philosophische schule nämlich die schule
der store besonders beliebt ist zurzeit
ist historisch gesehen immer wieder in
krisenzeiten populär geworden so auch
jetzt beispielsweise social media
portale die daily story oder stories
today erfreuen sich großer beliebtheit
glauben sie selber dass die philosophie
der store also eine antike philosophie
die um die nullerjahre herum entstanden
ist glauben sie dass diese philosophie
spezifisch etwas beitragen kann der
krise also zunächst mal freue ich mich
immer darüber wenn abendländische
philosophie in größerer zahl gelesen
wird reflektiert wird menschen sich
damit beschäftigen
man muss natürlich gehst du nicht allzu
ernst nehmen wenn man sie als
lebensratgeber benutzen will
wenn dies so heißt ein sehr
kompliziertes denkt gebäude auch kein
einheitliches ist von denker zu denker
sehr sehr stark verändert worden und die
menschen beschäftigen sich ja nicht mit
dem gesamten antiken gedankengebäude
oder all den lehrern sondern sie suchen
sich mehr oder weniger sinnsprüche oder
einfache weisheiten daraus aus und das
kann man machen dass es legitim das hat
er mit dem story kann nicht ganz so viel
zu tun wie man vielleicht denkt aber ich
meine wende ist an einem dazu hilft
gelassener zu sein wenn man tatsächlich
morgens auch
und sich als erstes sagt was ein kleines
nicht man eigentlich ist auch für wenige
dinge man eigentlich einfluss hat dass
man sich kulig zu wichtig nehmen sollte
und dass man so leben sollte dass man
immer reflektiert dass staatliches wesen
ist und dass man derzeit auf erden
sinnvoll nutzen soll
das sind ja weisheiten die nicht nur von
der starcom aber die bei den story kann
sie sprechen jetzt eine idee schon an
nämlich diese relativierung innerhalb
des kosmos zum beispiel zu erkennen dass
man nur so ein ganz kleines teilchen ist
vielleicht auch dass unser leiden jetzt
eigentlich angesichts der welt
angesichts der geschichte gar nicht so
bedeutend ist es gibt viele andere
rezepte und etwas was sie aufgreifen
auch in ihrem neuesten buch künstliche
intelligenz und der sinn des lebens ist
dass sie glauben es gibt so eine glücks
idee oder eine idee der zufriedenheit in
der story überzeugt nämlich diese
vorstellung dass zufriedenheit vor allem
darin besteht in einem souveränen sich
abfinden mit der situation und sie sagen
was sie eigentlich heute machen ist
überhaupt nicht uns souverän damit
abfinden wollen wir brauchen immer den
neuen kick den neuen clip wir brauchen
die likes wir brauchen das dieses daum
berieseln
und was haben sich ein problem ja da
sind es ist natürlich eine wichtige
konditionierung unseres
wirtschaftssystems dass wir nie
dauerhaft zufrieden sein soll also das
schlimmste was einem kapitalistischen
wirtschaftssystem passieren kann sind
menschen die mit wenigen dingen
dauerhaft zufrieden sind und deswegen
wird natürlich mit einem milliarden
aufwand an geld und werbung den menschen
pausenlos versucht bedürfnisse
einzutrichtern die sie nicht haben
das wiederum führt dazu dass viele
menschen mit dem was sie haben nicht
zufrieden sind sondern dass eine
unzufriedenheit entsteht die durch neue
waren oder neue reisen oder sowas
gestillt werden soll
das heißt es gibt also einen
grundlegenden widerspruch zwischen der
art und weise wie unsere wirtschaft
funktioniert und dem was uns glücklich
war das ist eigentlich auch ziemlich
vielen leuten bekannt ob das im
zusammenhang meines buches über
künstliche intelligenz deswegen noch mal
erzählt weil wir hier ja zu neuen
horizonten aufbrechen weil der und als
unsere wirtschaft noch weiter digital
optimieren wir wollen auch den menschen
immer
optimieren ich bin mir nicht so sicher
dass optimierung unweigerlich dazu führt
dass er glücklich
das ist bestimmt ein wichtiger punkt sie
haben aber etwas auch angesprochen was
mich sehr interessiert nämlich die frage
wie viel dieses sich sehnen uns nach
zuspruch nach likes nach einem der gunst
der anderen liegt sozusagen in uns
angelegt natürlicherweise auch um wie
viel wird uns auch von den maschinen
sozusagen eingetrichtert es gibt auch
immer wieder diese diskussion dass uns
diese verschiedenen technologien auch
süchtig machen das ist etwas in uns
träger was dann dauernd dazu führt dass
wir noch mehr wollen dass wir eben
gezeigt werden geteilt werden in
kommentaren erwähnt und so weiter also
meine frage ist wie sehr sind wir
einfach keine stoica auch wenn wir es
gerne wären und wie sehr für die
technologie dazu dass sozusagen der
stoizismus in uns noch mehr zum
verschwinden gebracht wird
also sie haben natürlich völlig recht
dass wir immer wieder getriggert werden
immer wieder mit neuen reizen
konfrontiert sind die genau das
gegenteil in uns bewirken als gelassen
zu werden und ich hatte ja gerade
erklärt dass es unserem
wirtschaftssystem eigentlich auch kaum
anders möglich ist und dass die
digitalisierung das ganze verstärkt zu
ihrer frage ist der mensch von natur aus
so oder nicht haben wir natürlich das
übliche problem ja philosophen sie
wissen das ja auch eine hervorragende
philosophin den menschen gibt es nicht
menschen sind sehr verschieden und wer
den menschen definieren will er will im
regelfall deswegen nicht mit menschen
die die gar nicht so eine riesen
bedürfnis danach haben ständig nach
neuem zu gieren und es gibt andere
menschen die haben dass das kann auch
von bei jedem menschen im laufe seines
alters unterschiedlich sein
das liegt in der natur junger menschen
dass sie sehr viele reize im regelfall
empfangen wollen uns sehr viele gigs und
aufregungen abenteuer erleben wollen und
älterer mensch dass das eis weniger und
deswegen ist es sehr schwierig die
menschen zu generalisieren
alles was wir sagen können ist dass wir
im augenblick bestimmte seiten unseres
seins oder unseres menschseins enorm
stimulieren oder sagen wir pausenlos
ungerührt versetzen und dass wir andere
gemüt und seelen kräfte die wir haben
darüber vernachlässigen und so erkläre
ihm ja auch dass es viele menschen gibt
in diesen gehetzten welten leben gerne
zuflucht zu büchern nehmen in denen von
denen sie sich warten oder versprechen
dass sie so mehr gebetsruf und diese
gemütsruhe wie sie es beschreiben ich
tatsächlich sind ideal auch die stille
menschen gehen in schweige retreats in
an orte an dem es wenig geräusche gibt
um zur ruhe zu kommen
nun geht ja die story noch weit dass sie
spricht vom ideal der apathie also
wirklich der leidenschaftslosen kite man
sollte den widerstreit emotionen dem
sich ganz zum verschwinden bringen zum
schweigen bringen und das interessiert
mich weil sie nämlich in diesem buch
über die künstliche intelligenz auch
sagen was eigentlich die idee der
emotionalen sensitivität dass wir
aufeinander reagieren mit leidenschaften
mit gefühlen wesentlich menschlich ist
und gerade das count künstliche
intelligenz nicht das heißt es wäre für
sie kein ideal wenn alle gefühle
verschwinden werden uns also ich kann
das historische ideal der fälligen
gemütsruhe er hat hier nicht
nachvollziehen man abgesehen davon dass
es keine erfindung der historiker ist
sondern dass wir das auch vorher schon
haben bei demokrit zum beispiel oder das
hat eine lange griechische tradition die
griechen haben zwei und ideale das eine
ist eben die die maximale gelassenheit
die apathie und das andere ist die
vortrefflichkeit und beide philosophien
operieren damit dass sie sagen es ist
einfacher zu erreichen wenn man seine
leidenschaft gestartet so gut hält und
die mehr kommt diese historische ideal
des leidenschaftslosen menschen kommt ja
ein bisschen vor wie mister spock im
raumschiff enterprise
was ich glaube dieses ideal ist
tatsächlich nicht für menschen gemacht
sondern für vulkania ich weiß gar nicht
wie eine menschliche zivilisation
aussehen soll
in der alle menschen nach optimaler
gemütsruhe im sinne von
leidenschaftslosen strebt also da möchte
ich an rousseau erinnern der mal gesagt
hat nicht diejenigen menschen haben am
meisten gelebt die am ältesten geraten
sind sondern die die am meisten gefühlt
haben aber die kunst besteht nicht darin
seine gefühle zu unterdrücken
los werden und dann die kunst besteht
darin ein irgendwie kunstvollen umgang
mit den eigenen gefühlen und dieses
beispiel mit den mit dem mister spock
raumschiff enterprise das kommt ja auch
vor in ihrem buch erkenne die welt der
erste verlierer großen
philosophiegeschichte drei bände in der
sie den bogen spannen von den anfängen
der philosophie bis ins heute rein etwas
was mich schon noch interessiert bevor
wir auf diese leidenschaften
zurückkommen
gerade da hat sie diese philosophie
geschichten geschrieben haben wenn man
so weit zurückgeht sie haben vorhin
gesagt der mensch den menschen gibt es
gar nicht wir sind alle ganz
unterschiedlich trotzdem gibt es ja so
was wie die menschliche natur aus das
hat mir mal als etwas mehr oder weniger
gleich bleiben dass das sich durch zieht
aber kann man den philosophien die
geschrieben worden sind vor mehr als
2000 jahre heute wirklich noch anwenden
sind nicht unsere welten so
unterschiedlich dass das gar nicht mehr
so richtig passt oder was würden sie
sagen was ich sozusagen die quintessenz
was wir noch mit ins heute nehmen können
ja also wie ich am anfang gesagt habe
den zuspruch den die historische
philosophie heute als lebensratgeber
oder als sammlung von weisheiten hat ihm
verdankt sie dadurch dass wir den alten
kontext ausblenden in der die
historische philosophie ursprünglich
entstanden
historiker haben eine menge dinge in
versucht zu systematisieren oder in ihr
system zu integrieren
für heute kein hahn danach gekräht also
sie waren der überzeugung dass der ganze
bosnische zyklus in dem die natur sich
befindet aus einem einzigen entstehen
und vergehen besteht
wir waren der überzeugung dass sich die
geschichte pausenlos wiederholt also
alle 2000 jahre kommt ein großer
weltenbrand der zerstört die erde und
dann werden alle menschen wiedergeboren
und müssen das gleiche fatalistische
leben leben was ihr beim ersten mal
erlebt haben wir dann wieder zerstört
wird und so weiter und so weiter als nur
ein beispiel
bitte noch einige andere beispiele auf
den wir heute hier zeigt eine große
verführungskraft mehr haben die man aber
verstehen muss wenn man verstehen will
wie die historiker die welt gesehen
haben und ebenfalls vergessen ist
eigentlich dass die historische
philosophie kein lebensratgeber um des
lebens
da war sein wollte sondern eminent
politische philosophie also in ihren
anfängen erträumten historiker bei zenon
von von einer art kommunistischen
gemeinschaft und am ende war sie
staatsphilosophie im römischen reich und
diente dazu die machtansprüche des
imperiums zu rechtfertigen
also je mehr man sich mit der insel kann
beschäftigt und so mehr sie anders
baldige geschichte das ist und wenn die
leute heute an die story denken und
fragen was ist davon geblieben
dann bleiben am ende meistens die spruch
sammlung von marc aurel übrig der dir
gar nicht so wirklich so die schiffe nur
soviel sind so ein best of der
griechischen philosophie da ist ganz
viel egoismus drin und auch diese so
wunderbar formulierten und geschliffenen
den schönsten griechisch geschriebenen
cars und spruch sammlungen muss man wenn
man es ganz ehrlich und vernahm
betrachtet unter dem gesichtspunkt sehen
dass sich zu dem zeitpunkt marc aurel an
der grenze in germanien befand der donau
als er das niederschrieb und
gleichzeitig die blutigste und
grausamste christenverfolgung aller
zeiten initiiert ich kann das buch nicht
lesen ohne dass wir so ein leichter
schauer den rücken runter aber es ist
ein wichtiger punkt dass sie gerade
erwähnt haben diese idee dass das
einfach vor einem kreativ muss ist eine
stilllegung sozusagen unsere emotionen
und jeder ist in seinem häuschen und
meditiert ein bisschen das ist nicht
starr sondern gerade eben auch in den
anfängen aber auch in der hochblüte zeit
eine politische theorie auch wir sollen
auch uns umeinander bemühen
ich würde gerne noch einmal zurück zu
den emotionen und dem was sie eben sagen
in diesem buch über die künstliche
intelligenz dass sie sagen die maschinen
die ki die wird nie diese emotionale
sensitivität entwickeln können
da würde mich interessieren ist das
einfach eine beschreibung von ihnen dass
sie sagen die werden das nicht können hh
wir haben doch einen vorteil wir können
doch was mehr oder sagen sie das ist
auch wahnsinnig gefährlich weil wenn die
ki übernimmt und darf nicht beherrscht
dann entsteht ein großes problem ja dann
entsteht etwas unmenschliches also
maschinen können keine emotionen
empfinden weil sie keine menschliche
physiologie haben das ist einfach der
grund also die menschliche sensibilität
und
die sensitivität hier entspringt ja
nicht aus unserem gehirn sondern
entspringt aus unseren sinnesorganen aus
unserer körper physiologie und so lange
künstliche intelligenz nicht über
menschen artige oder animalische körper
verfügt so lange kann sie nicht die
menschen emotionen empfinden und es ist
eine sehr merkwürdige irrglaube dem der
eine oder andere mathematiker
informatiker oder techniker anhängen zu
glauben die welt wäre besser wenn ihr
nicht mehr geführt wurde
und ehrlich gesagt wäre die welt fertig
sind und reizlos wenn wir keine gefühle
mehr befinden würden aber allein durch
die logik und die rationalität wird
nichts in dieser welt wirklich kommen
behalten
und abgesehen davon auf die weißeste und
klügste entscheidung ist am ende von
emotional im lancia abhängig also ohne
unsere gefühle weiß unser verstand
eigentlich überhaupt nicht was gemacht
aber da gibt es vielleicht ein eher eine
interessante idee von roberto simanowski
roberta simanowski ein buch geschrieben
mit dem titel todes algorithmus wo es
sich natürlich darüber eine maus lässt
wie im maschinellen lernen in diesem
ganzen selbstfahrenden autos die
algorithmen eine form von ethik den
maschinen eingepflanzt wird und er will
jetzt die interessante frage auf ob im
endeffekt wenn dir der calle diese
entscheidung überlassen würden die welt
nicht gerecht würde
gerade weil sie emotionslos ist würde
denn unsere emotionen unser mitleid sage
ich jetzt auch mal ist ja immer auch
partei wir haben sehr viel schneller
mitleid mit menschen die wir kennen
menschen die uns sympathisch sind
menschen die zu unserer familie gehören
oder zu unserem umfeld und deswegen sagt
er
man könnte ja hingehen und sagen wir
lassen die politik machen wird im
endeffekt die welt vielleicht gerechter
gerade weil sie emotionslos ist ist eine
lustige selbst widersprüchliche idee
gerechtigkeit ist letztendlich auch eine
emotion
also es gibt ein gerechtigkeitsgefühl
wir haben eine art gerechtigkeitssinn
man kann keine ein mathematische
gerechtigkeit herstellen
und deswegen ist die vorstellung man
könnte eine rechenmaschine erfinden die
immer genau ausrechnet was gerecht und
was ungerecht ist etwas was der
menschliche moral zutiefst widerspricht
das heißt also wenn in jeder dilemma
sind
portionen maschinen etwas ausrechnen
wird es niemals zu gerechtigkeit führen
weil die emotionen die für gerechtigkeit
zentral sind aus dieser gleichung
ausgeführt
das ist ein trugschluss das ist
interessant diese apodiktisch die sie
jetzt auch rein bringen weil ich schon
auch sehen kann was zb fritz breithaupt
auch mal gesagt hat die dunkle seite der
empathie
was wir jetzt ja wo wir aus menschen
agieren auch nicht für gerechtigkeit
sorgen sondern wir sorgen eben sehr viel
stärker für die unseren
nun könnte man sagen na ja genau das ist
eben menschlich
ja also es ist natürlich so nicht alles
was menschliches ist deswegen
unweigerlich positiv das ist schon
völlig richtig so und moral hat einen
sehr sehr hohen subjektiven
individuellen anteil
und sie haben das ja gerade selber
gesagt das leben meine kinder es steht
mehr näher als das leben von unbekannten
und so weiter und ich war am ende das
macht das ganze sehr und perfekt aber es
ist gut so dass du es weil alle unsere
ideen und unsere vorstellungen von
gerechtigkeit ohne emotionalität gar
nicht erst auf denkbar sind
sie hätten gar nicht das bedürfnis die
welt gerecht zu machen wenn wir nicht
das gefühl hätten sie solche gerecht
sein und deswegen noch mal genau darüber
nachdenken dass raus kurzen der
emotionalität aus der gerechtigkeits
diskussion schafft zwar am ende
mathematische gleichung oder in abwägung
habe es schafft keine gerechtigkeit die
das war das was ich gerade gesagt habe
dass sie selbst widersprüchlich ein
solches ich sehe die sendung läuft die
zeit läuft auch ich würde gerne zum
schluss noch mit ihnen darüber sprechen
dass sie sagen es gibt noch einen
widerspruch bei den stoiker nämlich dass
diese gemütsruhe eigentlich die folge
ist bei den stoiker von ganz viel arbeit
wir müssen ganz vielen arbeiten uns
stück weit auch zusammen reißen uns
loslösen von den ideen und dann kommt
die gemütsruhe von mark aurel stammt der
auch wiederum kalenderspruch das gute
leben sehr viel mehr einbringen ist als
ein tanzen
glauben sie dass ja also also historiker
haben ja schon eine menge griechische
philosophie vorgefunden also einerseits
auf das ideale gemüt
das bei bürgern und bei demokrit gibt
und auf der anderen seite das ideal der
vortrefflichkeit dass es für platon und
aristoteles gibt man hat versucht das
beides miteinander zu verschmelzen
der unterschied ist nur an meiner
vortrefflichkeit kann ich arbeiten
das ist zentrales programm in der
politik balken der ethik von aristoteles
aber an meiner gemütsruhe kann ich nicht
arbeiten also wenn ich jetzt versuche
mit aller energie gelassener zu werden
dann ist das bereits ein wieder
man kann nicht auf ungeladene art und
weise gelassenheit erreichen und das ist
eben in einer gesellschaft in der
menschen denken man könnte alle
fähigkeiten vervollkommnet so wie man
sein haupt trainiert oder wie man seine
aufmerksamkeit schulen kann oder wie man
sprachen lernen kann
so könnte man gelassenheit lernen und
das war etwas was auch die historiker
glaubten und ehrlich gesagt glaube ich
nicht dass man wirklich lernen kann im
sinne von unabänderliche arbeit an sich
gelassener zu werden
das funktioniert maximal ein paar wochen
da sollte man sich einen als lohn gibt
nun ist in dieser pandemie für viele die
frage offen wie gehen wir weiter wo
haben wir vielleicht unsere ressourcen
persönlich an sie herr brecht gibt es
philosophen dir so finden die sie lesen
in der krise wo sie denken da kriege ich
wirklich etwas was mich auch
weiterbringt oder blicken sie lieber in
das schöne aquarium hinter ihnen wo die
fische noch schlafen
nein ich arbeite im augenblick in meinem
buch und beschäftige mich tatsächlich
mit jemand der eine große rolle in der
syrischen philosophie spielt nämlich
ried sehr hoch und zieht so groß
überlegungen zum pflichtgemäßen handelns
also ich finde dass die frage nach der
pflicht eine der zentralsten und
wichtigsten fragen in der krone an dem
die ist und ich würde um mindestens den
wichtigsten gedanken und der verbindung
war und corona noch einmal ganz
nachhaltig betonen das was wir uns im
augenblick ist das ist schon was
ziemlich gewaltiges aber es ist im
menschheits vergleich ist es nicht das
größte übel was einem widerfahren kann
die generation ballack ran muss für den
zweiten krieg erleben und generation der
urgroßeltern sogar den ersten und den
zweiten weltkrieg aus meiner
hierbei krone wieder fährt ist nicht das
am ende millionen tote da sein werden
und das was uns eher abgenötigt das ist
auch nicht leichen aus kellern zu bergen
oder als soldaten an der front zu
sterben oder andere umzubringen sondern
ein bisschen stoffe im gesicht vertragen
dann bis auf konsum zu verzichten und
leider leider meine freunde etwas
weniger zu sehen
ich glaube damit kann man am ende
mindestens viele schon ganz gut leben
wir sollten die situation sehr ernst ist
da nicht überdauert solange man auch
materiell ein gutes auskommen hat und da
müssen wir wahrscheinlich
staatlicherseits noch ein bisschen unter
die arme greifen davos nur dass selbst
die menschen die in die die menschen
geht da etwas material härter von
betroffenen sind leben immer noch in
deutlich gesegneter und umständen als 90
der welt wissen
auch das wäre sozusagen eine social wird
8 mit dieser stoischen betrachtung
schließen wir unser kurzes gespräch ich
danke ihnen ganz herzlich glaube ich
dass sich zeit genommen haben und mit
mir in dieses gespräch eingetaucht sind
vielen dank
frisch historische seelenruhe zu
erlangen ist also wie jetzt deutlich
geworden sein dürfte harte arbeit warum
das so ist und ob sich die arbeit lohnt
passt die philosophin und theologin anna
schriefl von der universität bonn und
sie sitzt nun bei mir ganz herzlich
willkommen frau schriefl ja vielen dank
für die einladung
frau schrieben sie haben ein viel
beachtetes buch geschrieben die
einführungen historische philosophie
wurde viel diskutiert sie persönlich
wenn jetzt in diesen krisenzeiten sind
lesen sie dann auch mal ein story kwk
oder machen sie historische übung also
nein ich bin keine praktizieren des
drücken müssen dies durchaus sympathisch
aber nein und ich bin tatsächlich auch
in zwei online foren wo es durch
philosophie diskutiert wird wo sich
menschen über ihre social praxis
austauschen aber ich bin da ehrlich
gesagt nur als beobachterinnen also ich
selber macht es nicht warum nicht ja mir
ist aufgefallen ist interessant dass
eben unter den akademischen philosophen
die sich auch zuerst war wie canon oder
die sich als praktizierende das dritter
verstehen eigentlich kann die
spezialisten sind für die antike
philosophie und ich glaube dass der
grund dafür darin liegt dass leute das
so wie ich die sich mit der geschichte
der philosophie befassen
skeptiker sind häufig von ihrem naturell
her skepsis heißt ja untersuchung die
skeptiker sind also leute die ihren
gegenstand untersuchen aber gleichzeitig
immer so eine art kritische distanz
waren zu ihrem gegenstand und das trifft
auf mich auf jeden fall auch zu also ich
mir ist die philosophie sehr sympathisch
aber ich schaue mich doch davor mich
dann so im vatis zu ihr zu bekennen
selbst ja es gibt aber schon leute die
sich emphatisch bekennen dazu zb massimo
bellucci ist ein historiker und der
schreibt solche bücher gelassen bleiben
mit dem strick an 52 lektionen fürs
leben es gibt viele solche ratgeber im
bereich der deutschen philosophie
sträuben sich ihnen da als akademikerin
die nackenhaare also bei blut jetzt erst
mal nicht und auch nicht bei gregori
lopez des page ist ein interessanter
fall weil da ja tatsächlich professor
ist die philosophie aber er kommt aus
der wissenschaftstheorie und es ist auf
jeden fall interessante frage warum sich
die super so gut vermarkten lässt
also es gibt ja seit der zeit der mitte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ohnehin ein
sehr großes interesse an der antiken
tätig innerhalb der akademischen
philosophie aber innerhalb des
akademischen des kurses konzentriert
sich eigentlich die theorie vor allem
auf aristoteles also die leute vertreten
aristotelische ansätze der tugend ethik
aber außerhalb des akademischen des
kurses konzentriert sich das interesse
eigentlich fast ausschließlich auf
historische ethik und das ist sehr
interessant warum also man muss sich
fragen warum das eigentlich so ist weil
die ist wichtig eigentlich schon in der
antike dafür kritisiert worden ist
besonders anspruchsvoll zu sein
besonders hart zu sein die menschliche
natur vielleicht sogar zu überschätzen
und deswegen ist es dann interessant
dass die akademiker alle irgendwie
aristotelische sein wollen aber die
außer akademische welt sich bemüht nach
der historischen ethik ausgerechnet zu
leben und darüber werden wir sprechen
diese härte die kamen ja vorhin auch
schon jahren gespräch mit richard david
precht gleich ganz kurz was ist das
überhaupt für eine epoche die
historische philosophie wann ist
entstanden und der gehört
also die die historische
philosophenschule die entstand im
hellenismus so ungefähr 300 vor christus
in athen
man muss dazu wissen dass athen in
dieser zeit so was war wie die
kulturhauptstadt griechenlands also wer
philosophie betreiben wollte ging nach
athen
dort waren einfach die schulen von
platon und aristoteles noch im betrieb
zu dieser zeit und das zog
wahrscheinlich eben die intellektuellen
aus ganz griechenland an
und in diesem intellektuellen klima
entstanden
daneben auch die drei großen
chinesischen philosophen schulen also
die editorische schule die skeptiker und
die historiker
dazu gibt es eine legende also 10
der begründer der istrischen
philosophenschule der soll der soll ein
erfolgreicher kaufmann gewesen sein was
dann in der neuen zeit auch immer betont
wird
und der soll dann nach einem schiffbruch
in athen gelandet sein und dort dann
eben ein umfangreiches studium der
philosophie aufgenommen haben unter
anderem in platons akademie wo er viele
jahre verbracht haben soll
und ungefähr 300 vor christus eben hat
er dann ja legende zufolge eben seine
eigene schule gegründet und zwar auf dem
marktplatz in athen hat sich dort mit
seinen eigenen schülern getroffen und
diese schule ist daneben auch nach ihrem
ort benannt worden wegen der säulen
sozusagen aus so heißt auch säulenhalle
und ist quasi der ort in dem
philosophiert worden ist und hat er
diese philosophie ungefähr 500 jahre
gedauert ist sozusagen bei uns aber vor
allem bekannt bezüglich der späten phase
der römischen store der späten phase der
store also zb marc aurel der römische
kaiser den kennen viele von so flotten
kalender sprüchen oder magneten am
kühlschrank oder auch eben seneca der
auch berater waffen kaiser nero oder
auch epiktet ein sklave der dann in die
freiheit entlassen worden ist man denkt
sich ja irgendwie eben historische
philosophie wir wissen schon ungefähr
was das ist mit dieser gemütsregung zu
über die wir noch sprechen werden aber
es waren 500 jahres waren
unterschiedlichste lenker und
lenkerinnen wahrscheinlich eher denker
gibt es überhaupt eine einheitlich ist
deutsche philosophie
ja also das ist eine schwierige frage
tatsächlich also ich glaube dass es
schon sinnvoll ist von scotia
philosophie zu sprechen
weil sich einfach diese
unterschiedlichen denker auch selbst in
dieser tradition eingeordnet haben und
gewisse intuitionen geteilt haben zum
beispiel das wissen von der welt
prinzipiell möglich ist es ist schwer
aber möglich zum beispiel dass das
universum dass der kosmos ein sinnvolles
ganzes ist so nicht ein zufallsprodukt
südkorea eben vertreten haben zum
beispiel das jugend wissen ist also als
solche intuitionen teilen die
andererseits muss man sich trotzdem
finde ich immer klar machen dass es ein
konstrukt ist von soja philosophie zu
sprechen weil es eben sehr
unterschiedliche denker sind die 500
jahre lang gewirkt haben die sehr viele
bücher publiziert haben die leider also
aus der frühen phase alle verloren sind
wir können die nicht lesen und vor allem
wir wissen dass es kontroversen gab das
ist sehr große kontroversen gab gerade
in der anfangsphase wahrscheinlich in
der in der gesamten zeit der session
philosophie und deswegen muss man sich
schon immer deutlich machen es ist auch
ein konstrukt das ist auch der
überlieferung lage geschuldet so zu
sagen dass wir von einer stoischen
philosophie sprechen und nicht von der
philosophie ziehen uns von der
philosophie krebs also das kann man
machen aber es ist sehr sehr schwierig
die auseinanderzuhalten einfach aufgrund
der überlieferung lage das eigentlich
die belieferung schlage das andere ist
auch die frage was lässt sich sozusagen
vermarkten darüber haben jetzt schon
mehrere male gesprochen also eben dass
sich sozusagen die geschenk bändchen die
schönen gut verkaufen das sind jetzt
keine geschenk bändchen aber schriften
von mark aurel oder seine k gibt es
jetzt eben an vielen orten schön
gebunden zur weihnachtszeit zu erstehen
es gibt auch viele social media portale
auf denen eben strickerinnen moderne
historiker miteinander diskutieren wie
man sein leben könnte
interessant daran ist ja vor allem dass
man eigentlich die philosophie auch ein
bisschen amputiert weil dieses
philosophische gebäude immer drei
bestandteile eigentlich umfasst hat sie
selber bringen mit ihrem buch im design
schon zu stolzen philosophie was als
sinnbild 1 1 build a stupid love muss
eigentlich geprägt hat erzählen sie mal
was hat das zu tun mit deutsch
philosophie
ja es gibt unterschiedliche bilder für
diese auffassung dass die trophy eine
große einheit bilden soll also die
stricker denken die meistens durch
denken dass die
philosophie ein system ist aus drei
verschiedenen bereichen ethik logik und
physik und das steht für dieses bild das
eben alle drei teile eigenständigen
beitrag zu diesen großen ganzen liefern
und keinem dieser teile jetzt priorität
zukommt also wir brauchen die eierschale
gebrauchen das eiweiß und wir brauchen
den dotter sonst haben wir nichts sonst
haben wir es nicht mit einem zu tun und
die meistens drücker sind eben dieser
auffassung dass ist diese drei teile
geben muss es gibt eben auch abweichler
es gibt einen gewissen aristo der sagt
nein
die wir wir müssen eigentlich nicht
wirklich physik und logik betreiben die
ethik ist der wirklich der wichtigste
teil
aber das ist die die nicht die orthodoxe
historische auffassung und nun das
vielleicht noch besser zu verstehen also
die die schale ist ja die logik das
eiweiß ist die ethik der dotter ist die
physik und die idee ist ungefähr man
kann zum beispiel nicht gut sein also
ethische maxime ohne die schale
verstanden zu haben ohne auch vernünftig
zu sein ohne auch eben logos logik zu
haben
ist das richtig ja das ist richtig also
wir wir brauchen alle drei teile der der
philosophie um das historische wissen zu
erreichen dass sie dann auch mit der
tugend identifizieren
aber die betonen doch dass es nicht dass
es nicht instrumentell ist also es ist
nicht so dass wir nur logik betreiben
müssen um gute menschen zu sein und wir
müssen nicht nur für sich betreiben um
zum beispiel unserem platz im kosmos zu
verstehen sondern diese teile haben auch
einen eigenen wert also die haben schon
eine gewisse eigenständigkeit man kann
es nicht reduzieren auf die ethik dass
es zumindest die historische orthodoxie
da unterscheiden sich die historiker
auch ein bisschen von dem pico ruivo das
so zu sein scheint dass man für sich vor
allem deswegen betreiben muss um
seelenruhe zu erreichen zum beispiel
gehen wir aber jetzt doch mal zum weiß
also zu ethik war das wahrscheinlich
schon so ungefähr das thema ist eben
etwas sehr viele leute anspricht muss
eben nachher so bücher gibt gelassen
bleiben mit den stickern ganze kurve
auch eine story eine weltweite bewegung
spiel als der krieg auch in irland da
kann man sich dann ein schreiben
eine woche lang versuchen stoica zu sein
und da etwas zu lernen für sich fürs
leben noch und wenn jetzt über dieses
eiweiß über die ethik sprechen dann
gibt's ja etwas was wirklich sehr
auffällig ist nämlich dass das was eben
zu tun hat mit dieser ethik eben immer
auch zu tun hat mit vernunft also zum
beispiel ist die idee das gute leben ist
auch eine technik also etwas was man
erst mal erkennen muss und beim einüben
muss also harte praxis also das heißt
gut zu werden ist auch kopfsache
ja genau also und da unterscheiden sich
die strecke tatsächlich von anderen
ansätzen der antike sie würden sagen die
menschliche tugend oder halbrechts hat
gerade von vortrefflichkeit gesprochen
also die menschliche vortrefflichkeit
besteht eben vor allem darin unsere
vernunft zu schulen es dies durch sind
der ansicht es gibt sozusagen keine
teilen uns die wirklich rational sind
die wirklich nicht zugänglich sind
der vernunft und das heißt unseren
charakter zu spielen heißt wesentlich
unser denken zu schulen
also das heißt zum beispiel auch wenn
ich jetzt nein die spinnen oder
eifersüchtig oder wütend dann sind das
nicht irgendwelche natur witzigen
irgendwie ein natur witziges rumoren in
meinen eingeweiden was mein denken
überschwappt sondern das ist eine
täuschung in meinem denken genau also
das ist dieses durch die emotions
theorie die die diskutiert wurde dies
durch denken tatsächlich im widerspruch
zu den meisten anderen philosophen der
philosophiegeschichte dass emotionen
unserem denken nicht entgegengesetzt
sind sondern emotionen sind meinungen
das heißt emotionen sind so was wie
urteile die ich bilde und deswegen sind
sie auch in unserer in unserer kontrolle
also aus diesem grund können wir unsere
emotionen auch steuern es ist zwar
schwer weil es nicht sehr leicht ist
unser denken zu schulen ist es harte
arbeit so zu sagen aber es ist möglich
und das ist natürlich ein großer
anknüpfungspunkt gewesen für die
kognitive verhaltenstherapie die sich
explizit auf die schulter beruft
und die auch den klienten manchmal
epiktet oder andere autoren zum lesen
mit gibt das ist sozusagen die die die
die zentrale intuition dass unsere
emotionen keine unwillkürlichen
reaktionen sind auf die außenwelt
sondern unsere eigenen meinungen die wir
selbst bilden ja also kognitive
verhaltenstherapie zum beispiel jemand
hat angst vor spinnen dann geht es
irgendwie darum zu lernen
diese spinne die macht mir gar nichts
ich kann mich informieren über spinnen
ich weiß dies nicht giftig wenn die da
an der wand steht dann habe ich nur so
einen fluchtreflex weil das irgendwie
keine ahnung evolutionsbiologisch sich
erklären lässt und dadurch soll ich dann
lernen meine angst abzubauen
genau also irrationale angst vor spinnen
das sind das einfach eine meinung und
zwar eine falsche meinung und die
interessanterweise denken dass diese
eben nicht nur über solche unangenehmen
emotionen sondern eigentlich über alle
an alle emotionen sind rationale
reaktionen falsche also
fehleinschätzungen der außenwelt auch
wenn ich mich verliebe sehr gute frage
also dass das ideal der drucker ist
tatsächlich die freiheit von effekten
die freiheit von ebendiesen rationalen
station meinungen über die außenwelt
aber ich glaube das heißt nicht dass wir
keine gefühle haben dürfen oder dass das
ideal des der stricker ist dass man
vollkommen regungslos durch das leben
geht es gibt positive emotionen und das
sind glaube ich wirklich gerne meine
gefühle und die stellen sich aber gerade
dann ein wenn man die wenn man die welt
richtig einschätzt und zu diesen
emotionen gehört zum beispiel die freude
zu denen gehört auch die zuneigung zu
anderen menschen die die schulter eben
für sehr wichtig halten
also ich glaube nicht dass sie sagen
würden man darf sich nicht verlieben
oder die ich glaube auch nicht dass dass
es richtig ist zu sagen dass die zürcher
denken
der tod eines geliebten menschen würde
uns überall so den sollen wird völlig
regungslos hinnehmen ich glaub ja ja
aber das steht doch berlin ist das bei
senica oder bei wien war das oder cicero
liegen wo steht das doch dass wenn das
eigene kind stirbt
ja dass das ja zum leben dazugehört
sollte man hat wenn man kinder kriegt
sich früh schon überlegen dass das kind
auch wieder sterben kann
trinkt schon na ja nicht nur emotionslos
noch nicht kalt also natürlich also es
ist es ist ein hoher anspruch so zu
sagen wir sollen mit diesem ereignis
rational umgehen
und gerade diese diese dies durch
erfassung zum tod hat schon in der
antike kontroversen verursacht also
cicero singt mit dieser theorie dass wir
dies dass wir solchen ereignissen
rational begegnen sollen man muss sich
ja auch vor allem vorstellen dass dort
der tod der eigenen kinder das zu dieser
zeit der tod der eigenen kinder sehr
viel wahrscheinlicher war als heute und
zwar nicht nur der eigenen kind der tod
der kinder im kindesalter sondern zum
beispiel auch der tod der erwachsenen
töchter bei der geburt der eig der der
enkelkinder und genau das dass cicero
passiert also cicero hat seine tochter
verloren die nach der geburt ihres
zweiten sohnes im wochenbett gestorben
ist und cicero ringt mit dem
historischen ideal und überlegt eben was
jetzt genau von ihm gefordert ist wie er
mit diesem ereignis wirklich rational
umgehen soll
aber ich glaube eben nicht dass es
bedeutet dass wir vollkommen regungslos
diese ereignisse hinnehmen sondern was
die schulter empfehlen ist also die
sogar denken selbst der social weise der
vollendet ist in seiner tugendhat
natürlich hunger durst und so weiter
also es gibt regungen und er reagiert
natürlich auch wenn wenn nächst stehende
personen sterben oder ein modell von
schwerer krankheit betroffen sind aber
die idee es so zu sagen wir können uns
nicht aussuchen welche gedanken sich
welche eindrücke wir haben welche
vorstellungen wir haben aber wir können
uns trotzdem immer zu ihnen verhalten
das sollte sich dieses diese sozusagen
idee wir können schreiben wir können wir
können nicht kontrollieren die die welt
ist da wir können kontrollieren wie wir
der welt gegenüber empfinden das gibt
uns eigentlich freiheit es gibt uns
distanz und das leuchtet ja auch vielen
ein und macht sich auch den zauber
dieser philosophie aus vielleicht auch
noch ein anderes bild diese idee bei
senica glaube ich das
wer sowie tiere sind und einen wagen
gespannt und der wagen wird gelenk der
geht hat in eine richtung solange wir an
dieser leine zerren werden wir gewirkt
also wir werden hinter her geschleift es
wird uns diese leine wenn ihr uns
reinschicken ins schicksal und fügsam
hinterher trotzen hinter dem wagen dann
haben wir plötzlich wieder luft zum
atmen
das leuchtet einem jahr eigentlich ein
ja genau und das sollte mir dann eben
besonders bei solchen ereignissen machen
also wir sollten eben dann beim tod
geliebter menschen zum beispiel nicht
denken oh gott was für eine
naturkatastrophe sondern ist sollte uns
klar sein es ist ein völlig normaler
bestandteil eigentlich jedes
menschenlebens dass so etwas passiert es
nützt uns nichts zu denken dass das
jetzt irgendwie die ausnahmesituation
sondern eben krisen dieser art oder
sogenannte krisen dieser art sind ein
völlig normaler bestandteil des
menschenlebens wir sind nunmal staatlich
wir haben körper das heißt wir können
krank werden
es ist völlig normal dass man auch in
freundschaften enttäuscht wird oder
sowas und es ist nützt uns nichts uns
dagegen aufzulehnen sondern wir sollten
uns klar machen dass das einfach zum
menschlichen leben dazugehört
und ja sogar in dieses so genannten pre
meditation album uns immer wieder wie in
einer inneren meditation darauf
konzentrieren was noch sehr viel
schlimmeres passieren könnte was das
schlimmstmögliche überhaupt wäre und
sozusagen die nachdenken über diesen
abgrund auch unsere kräfte wieder
mobilisieren und wissen sein das
schlimmste käme wäre ich dafür gewappnet
damit uns nicht unvorbereitet trifft ja
genau und dann denkt man häufig das ist
irgendwie so eine art zweckpessimismus
also die größten pessimisten und die
pessimistische ich die welt sehe desto
weniger wäre ich dann von mir enttäuscht
ich glaube dass es eigentlich nicht
stimmt also ich glaube die straßen
eigentlich optimisten
sie sind der ansicht dass die welt
bestmöglich für uns eingerichtet ist und
dass wenn die sie wirklich verstehen wir
auch zusagen sehen dass dieses ereignis
ja eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm sind
sondern einfach bestandteil der conditio
humana ja und da sehen wir wieder jetzt
kommen sie mit dem doktor nämlich mit
der physik oder auch der kosmologie der
mensch hat einen platz im kosmos dann
ist natürlich das eigene ende oder das
laufende sandro gar nicht so schlimm
weil hier irgendwie aufgehoben sind in
einem
großen ganzen ich würde gerne noch
einmal zurück zum bild mit dem
wagenlenker und dem tier an der leine
zerrt wir mal an jemand wird verlassen
ein mann wird verlassen von seiner frau
ist komplett verzweifelt er ist
enttäuscht er liebt diese frauen auch er
möchte nicht dass sie geht wie findet er
heraus ob sich das zerren und alleine
noch lohnt also das aufbegehren oder ob
er sich führen soll war wenn man sich zu
früh fügt man kriegt man doch auch
nichts im leben ja gute frage also ich
glaube dass das auch sozusagen in der
modernen rezeption der spanne große
rolle spielt weil das da so häufig also
nachdem man sich da beobachtet habe in
diesen foren
da gibt es häufig um den umgang mit
misserfolg und um sozusagen um
beharrlichkeit gerade in der
konfrontation mit mit set bergs mit mit
mit eben rückschlägen im leben oder so
und irgendwie ein erfolgsrezept scheint
zu sein dieser modernen stücke das hier
niederlagen eben nicht als anlass nehmen
sollen vier großen von der selbstkritik
sondern wir sollten einfach weitergehen
einfach weitermachen ich ja und es ist
nicht mit der frage also zu sagen wann
wann soll ich mich dem schicksal fügen
oder aber nicht da das fällt mir auch
ein also ist es ja irgendwie eine eine
sehr verbreitete deutung der strecke zu
sagen die sind unpolitisch also sagen
die schulter empfehlen dass sie auch
politische verhältnisse einfach so
hinnehmen sollen weil das hört ja
sozusagen zu den dingen die außerhalb
unserer eigenen kontrolle liegen nur
unser charakter liegt innerhalb unserer
eigenen kontrolle und die politischen
ausgefeilten sozusagen das gehört zu den
dingen die wir einfach so unhinterfragt
akzeptieren sollen ich glaube dass das
nicht stimmt also ich glaube dass die
historische ethik sehr wohl vereinbar
ist mit politischem aktivismus und das
wird auch empfohlen schon in der schon
in den frühen phasen der store auch die
idee dass der weise seine einsichten
nutzt um die politik zu verändern also
zb aktivistin zu werden bei plug live
special
durchaus im sinne der store weil es
nicht darum geht sich überhaupt nicht zu
engagieren
genau also ist also man ist ja irgendwie
ein großes eine eine große einsicht dass
wir diese dinge unterscheiden müssen was
bei uns liegt und was nicht bei uns
liegt aber es liegt nun mal bei uns
ungerechtigkeiten zu erkennen und etwas
dagegen zu unternehmen
und natürlich also in einigen kreisen
der modernen star wird das sehr kritisch
gesehen also da zählt dann auch blätter
als head group und das und und und und
jegliche art von anti rassistischen oder
zumindest im engagement gilt irgendwie
als hysterisch und nicht und und uns
durch und so weiter aber ich glaube dass
das wirklich ein missverständnis ist die
strecke haben eben von beginn an sich
politisch engagiert in der weise wie es
eben damals möglich war also zur zur in
der großteil der zeit in der die sich
aktiv waren war war gab es könige und
kaiser und die historiker haben sich
daneben auch als berater zum beispiel
engagiert oder eben lokal und wenn wir
beim wagenlenker nur vom beispiel vorher
war die frage wahrscheinlich doch nicht
beantwortet haben da könnte man ja auch
sagen das tier das er sich jetzt ein
tier kein mensch aber aus mensch wenn
wir ein tier wären und das alleine dann
geht es eben darum zu sehen wo habe ich
kontrolle und wo habe ich sie nicht und
das gelassen annehmen was ich nicht
ändern kann und das eine vom anderen zu
unterscheiden braucht eben weisheits und
das ist wahrscheinlich etwas was ich
nicht von heute auf morgen ein stellt
sondern er kommt wahrscheinlich auch so
was mit ein wenig geduld haben mit der
situation ja genau und eben
wahrscheinlich auch immer wieder darüber
zu reflektieren und immer wieder sein
weltbild anzupassen die frage ist ob das
wirklich anhand von übungen passieren
muss also per auto ist der ansicht dass
es dass diese ist er nennt das
spirituelle übungen wirklich ein
zentraler bestandteil nicht nur der
späten store war sondern der gesamten
antiken philosophie und das ist
umstritten also andere leute denken es
geht wirklich einfach darum die eigene
lebensführung rational zu reflektieren
und das als ausgangspunkt zu nehmen das
muss dann nicht unbedingt eben in form
von übungen stattfinden sondern einfach
zum beispiel auch im diskursiven
austausch mit anderen
die prinzipien zu hinterfragen nach dem
man lebt das weltbild zu hinterfragen
nachdem man sein leben bewusst oder
unbewusst ausrichtet ist eigentlich eine
sehr reflexive philosophie das wird
schon sehr deutlich ich sehe dass die
sanduhr schon abgelaufen ist deswegen
möchte ich noch auf einen anderen aspekt
zu sprechen kommen bevor uns die zeit
davon läuft nämlich ihre käse auch die
sie auch an verschiedenen orten auch in
ihrem buch stark machen dass die social
philosophie so wunderbar sie ist in
ihrer modernen variante zum teil auch
vereinnahmt wird zb sagen sie
vereinnahmt wird von einem neoliberalen
wirtschaftsmodell was meinen sie damit
ja das ist ebenso interessant dass die
schulter so beliebt sind in silicon
valley in bei leuten die eben sich als
unternehmer verstehen und die
unternehmerischen erfolg erstritten und
dann gibt es immer große vorbilder die
sich auch mit der star schon befasst
haben also ist es glaube ich aber auch
einfach sehr nützlich für diese moderne
[ __ ] der store dass das kaiser mag
auch das tourist selbst bekennender
stricker war sozusagen der mächtigste
erfolgreichste mensch des damaligen
mittelmeerraums und das ist dann ein
vorbild für diese leute für solche leute
wie wie zum beispiel des weltraums die
ebenso ein start-up gegründet hat im
silicon valley
die aber eigentlich nur betrügerin war
aber die sich eben mit der station
philosophie auch geschmückt hat und das
ist interessant dass die ist ua das
zulässt sozusagen also immer wieder wird
der wird in strücken vorgeworfen dass
sie sozial konservativ sind eben genau
wegen dieser unterscheidung zwischen dem
was bei mir liegt und dem was außerhalb
meiner kontrolle liegt sozusagen sowas
zu predigen wie die verhältnisse sind
nun mal so wie sie sind und wir müssen
irgendwie versuchen innerhalb dieser
verhältnisse möglichst erfolgreich zu
werden also auch dieses credo ich bin
meines eigenen glückes schmied und
sozusagen das überwälzen aller
institutionellen schwierigkeiten die man
so haben kann auf die einzelnen personen
die doch eben lernen sollen mit den
nicht besonders freundlich in
arbeitsbedingungen zb selber umzugehen
also das ist zum beispiel so ein credo
von holiday der so ein guru es in dieser
historischen bewegung der dann immer
betont wir alle haben mit dem gleichen
hindernissen zu tun und es das stimmt
halt einfach überhaupt nicht also es ist
überhaupt nicht so dass wir alle die
gleichen hindernis
vorfinden sondern es gibt menschen die
sehr viel größer größere hindernisse
vorfinden wenn sie zb ökonomischen
erfolg anstreben als andere genau und
und da würden sie sagen wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe vereinnahmung vom
neoliberalismus weil eigentlich die
story person nicht hergibt weil die
story eigentlich mit menschlich war und
dazu aufgerufen hat sich für andere zu
engagieren
aber der moderne tourismus in dieser art
und weise lässt man diesen politischer
seite einfach weg genau also die antiken
stricker waren ja zum beispiel auch
kosmopoliten was auch immer sie damit
gemeint haben und wie man was auch immer
verstehen muss es gibt auf jeden fall
textfragmente in dem sie auch dazu
aufrufen dass wir die verbundenheit mit
allen anderen menschen kritisieren
müssen und dass das sozusagen eines der
wichtigsten ethischen ideale überhaupt
ist das fällt natürlich das völlig weg
sondern es geht darum irgendwie erfolg
zu haben in der jetzt bestehenden welt
eben durch ohne rücksicht auf verluste
da bleibt ein beiwagen heute ist es ein
bisschen so also ist es dient sozusagen
der rechtfertigung auch von ökonomischem
erfolg und das ist es wird dann nicht
hinterfragt wie auf welchen ethischen
prinzipien das eigentlich beruht ja und
vielleicht auch diese partie über die
wir schon gesprochen hatten
richard david precht also diese fast
schon gefühlskälte wenn man die
natürlich nicht richtig versteht also
nicht auch aus ein logisches denken hat
ein vernunft mäßiges denken was mit
erkenntnis zu tun hat sondern mehr aus
ein abschalten von mitleid zum beispiel
dann sind wir zum beispiel auch bei
james mattis ein general
verteidigungsminister unter einen donald
trump 2017 bis 2019 und ihr habt von
sich gesagt selbst im feld trägt er
immer so ein marc aurel büchlein bei
sich in der westentasche
weil einem das sozusagen zum zum
stählernen eisernen schlagkräftigen
soldaten macht ja ja genau und also dass
die strikers und sehr beliebt in diesen
kreisen das sollte einem wirklich zu
denken geben finde ich also ich finde es
auch interessant dass es so ist warum
die auch gerade in solchen kreisen zu
beliebt sind die so ein bestimmtes
männlichkeits ideal vertreten also es
geht darum die eigenen emotionen zu
kontrollieren
alles andere gilt irgendwie als
verweichlicht und als irgendwie
verweichlicht oder so und das sollte uns
auf jeden fall zu denken geben warum die
schulter das zu lassen
also das ist ja kein zufall warum diese
leute also ich denke mal dass es nicht
zum fall ist ich denke schon dass es mir
viel integration ist aber trotzdem ist
es so dass die zudem stark angreifen und
nicht zu aristoteles oder platten oder
eben zu den klinikern oder sowas
es gibt ja so eine zweite vereinnahmung
die sie beklagen und das ist mehr die
vereinnahmung sagen jetzt mal von den
antifeministen die sich natürlich gerne
darauf berufen dass die stadt sich auch
an der natur orientiert haben und die
sagen dann zum beispiel na ja die natur
hat zwei geschlechter geschaffen und
alle schattierungen die jetzt da
erfunden werden sie neben nicht
natürlich und deswegen ist für uns
wichtig so war der beweis dafür und die
richtige philosophie um wirklich noch
einmal zu zeigen wie die
geschlechterverhältnisse sind ja also
das ist für mich eine herausforderung
mit diesen gruppen umzugehen
das ist ja so dass also antifeministen
und rassisten sich jetzt nicht nur für
die schulter interessieren insgesamt
einfach sehr fasziniert sind von der
griechisch römischen antike und ich
finde schon dass spezialisten für die
griechisch römische antike sich mit
diesem mit diesem problem
auseinandersetzen müssen warum sich
diese rassisten und antisemiten so sehr
für sie interessieren aber eben das
stimmt schon
insbesondere die historiker ebenso eine
große faszination auf diese leute aus
und es ist noch mal also es gibt noch
einen unterschied zwischen diesen
zwischen den zwischen der
antikommunistischen aneignung und
einfach der rassistischen aneignung des
partners ist meistens dieselben gruppen
aber ist es wird auf verschiedene weise
oft getan
ja also eine eine weise damit umzugehen
ist schon glaube ich auf zu zeigen
inwiefern das viele interpretationen
sind aber wahrscheinlich reicht es nicht
also ich glaube ist es auf jeden fall
sind auf jeden fall viel interpretation
viele behaupten ja dass die sticker
sozusagen die feministische philosophie
der antike vertreten haben
es gibt überlegungen dazu dass zum
beispiel die tugend von mann und frau
dieselbe sein muss also klar es muss ein
buch darüber verfasst haben dass es eben
leider verloren wie alles andere was er
geschrieben hat
und sie ich denke eben dass dies durch
genau diesen naiven naturbegriff nicht
vertreten würden
also der papst sagt irgendwie auch so
was wir müssen die schöpfung bewahren
und daraus folgt aber auch wir müssen
die binäre geschlechterordnung bewahren
die er irgendwie für natur geben hält
dafür sollen es nur mann und frau gibt
schwarz und weiß genau und das würden
glaube ich die strecke einfach ablehnen
zumindest manche also die quellenlage
ist ja auch einfach so schlecht aber sie
würden ich glaube einige von ihnen
würden eben darauf würden eben im
gegensatz zu diesen leuten betonen dass
die vernunft natur zentral ist und dass
das sich eben zeigt dass die bei mann
und frau gleichermaßen vorliegen
ich finde das interessant ihnen
zuzuhören und auch dieses ringen
ihrerseits zu spüren weil sie natürlich
einer seitige texte sehr gut kennen eine
spezialistin sind für diese epoche auch
und es ihnen dann wahrscheinlich wehtut
zu sehen was aus diesen texten politisch
gemacht werden sie denken was steht doch
da überhaupt nicht damit muss man
wahrscheinlich als philosophiehistoriker
allen immer ein bisschen umgehen und
rechnen oder bei den story kann ist das
so weil die einfach so breit rezipiert
werden bei anderen friedhof die
trübungen ist es viel weniger so die die
werden viel weniger im aus akademischen
diskurs rezitiert aber ich finde schon
dass man sich eben diesem problem
stellen muss also das ist eine aufgabe
ist für uns die wir uns mit der
philosophie der antike beschäftigen und
auch damit auseinander zu setzen dass
sie eben in solchen fragwürdigen kreisen
zu hohe beliebtheit genießen
und ich hab jetzt keine eindeutige
antwort was wie wir damit umgehen sollen
weil einige von denen sich
wahrscheinlich auch überhaupt nicht
dafür interessieren was jetzt irgendwie
die korrekte auslegung ist dieser
quellen aber ich finde schon dass sie
uns damit auseinandersetzen müssen
ich meine man kann ja irgendwie auch
einfach trotzdem sagen muss ich jetzt
nichts schlechtes daran sich eben nur
mit dem eiweiss auseinanderzusetzen und
das auch zu genießen war so eine schrift
von mark aurel zu lesen oder so und sie
beschreiben in ihrem buch auch sie waren
lange zeit auch in den usa in der
forschung tätig wie sie selber in so
treffen gegangen sind
astoria in new york die sich da treffen
und wie sie das irgendwie auch berührt
hat diese gruppen die sich da treffen
und miteinander diskutieren ins
philosophieren kommen vielleicht zum
schluss noch welche rezepte der
deutschen philosophie sind vielleicht
doch so dass sie denken ja da kann man
wirklich was mitnehmen da kann man
wirklich etwas lernen gerade jetzt auch
für diese krise in der wir uns aktuell
befinden mit der pandemie also ich bin
tatsächlich dass die historische theorie
der emotionen attraktiv ist es ist
sozusagen die nicht statt theorie der
emotionen die sie vertreten aber ich
finde tatsächlich etwas für sich zu
denken dass emotionen nicht irgendwelche
unwillkürlichen reaktionen auf die
außenwelt sind sondern dass die sehr eng
zusammenhängen zumindest mit unseren
eigenen urteilen und dass wir deswegen
in gewisser weise sie kontrollieren
können und auch für sie verantwortlich
sind das finde ich auf jeden fall sehr
bedenkenswert auch bedenken dass werde
ich natürlich diese idee der
verbundenheit also sozusagen das hier
soziale lebewesen sind und dass wir auch
also eben in diesem in diesen
miteinander mit allem also in diesem in
diesen in dieser politischen
gemeinschaft unsere rolle finden müssen
faszinierend natürlich auch überhaupt
die ganze vorstellung der natur also die
historiker werden ja manchmal als
materialisten bezeichnet und das ist
glaube ich falsch die strikers sind es
sind zwar der ansicht dass es keine
transzendenten größen gibt aber sie sind
eben nicht der ansicht dass sich alles
auf materie beschränkt sondern es gibt
eben einordnung das prinzip dass dieser
materie gegenübersteht und das finde ich
finde ich auch faszinierend sozusagen
also dieses dieses tolle angebot neben
dem dualismus und neben dem
materialismus zu sagen es gibt zwar
nichts nichts nichts körperliches aber
es gibt ordnung genau es gibt ein organ
ist nicht einfach ein ungeordneter
teilchen hausen reiner zufall sondern es
gibt ordnung dass ich sozusagen die
essenz des ice nämlich der dotter genau
also das ei hat auf jeden fall
eine sinnvolle ordnung vielen herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch und für den
einblick in die historische philosophie
vielen dank für die einladung
nächste woche hat ich weiß hat hohen
besuch und das rad albers setz dich an
unseren tisch und philosophiert mit uns
über politische systeme übermacht im
bundeshaus und vielleicht auch über
historische ruhe in der krise und jetzt
gleich heißt vorhang auf für einen der
erfolgreichsten autoren des 19
jahrhunderts alexander huber lassen sie
sich entführen in eine welt voller
action und drama ich verabschiede mich
für dieses jahr von ihnen sage danke für
ihre treue und freue mich auf ein
wiedersehen im januar bleiben sie gesund
bis bald
[Musik]